Nos dicen: "Un cilindro de 10.0 L contiene
7.60 g de Ar(g) y 4.40 g de N₂(g) a 25°C.
Calcula la presión parcial de cada gas
y la presión total del cilindro". Bien,
pausa el video e intenta resolverlo por
tu cuenta antes de que trabajemos juntos.
Muy bien. Puedes imaginar que la Ley de
los gases ideales se puede aplicar aquí,
y es aplicable ya sea que sólo pensemos en las
presiones parciales de cada gas o en la presión
total. La Ley de los gases ideales nos dice que
la presión por el volumen es igual al número de
moles por la constante de los gases ideales por
la temperatura [PV = nRT], y en este caso estamos
intentando encontrar la presión, ya sea la presión
parcial o la presión total. Así que para despejar
la presión, podemos dividir a ambos lados entre V,
entonces obtenemos que la P = nRT/V. Podemos usar
esta expresión para encontrar la presión parcial
de cada uno de estos gases, entonces podemos decir
que la presión parcial del argón es igual al
número de moles del argón por la constante de
los gases ideales por la temperatura -ambos gases
están a la misma temperatura- entre el volumen;
además, podemos decir que la presión parcial
del nitrógeno molecular es igual al número de
moles del nitrógeno molecular por la constante
de los gases ideales por la temperatura entre el
volumen. Ahora bien, ya tenemos varios datos de
estas expresiones, podemos buscar la constante
de los gases ideales con las unidades apropiadas
por aquí, nos dan la temperatura en grados Celsius
-tendremos que convertirlos a grados Kelvin-, y
también nos dan el volumen. Entonces, lo único que
tenemos que hacer es calcular la cantidad de moles
de cada uno de éstos, y para calcular el número
de moles nos dan la masa, sólo tenemos que pensar
en la masa molar. Así que busquemos la masa molar
del argón y también la masa molar del nitrógeno
molecular. Si sacamos nuestra tabla periódica de
los elementos podemos ver el argón justo acá,
y su masa atómica promedio es de 39.95, lo que
también nos da su masa molar; entonces: 1 mol de
argón tiene una masa de 39.95 g/mol. Y, ahora,
si queremos encontrar lo mismo para el nitrógeno
molecular, podemos ver aquí que el nitrógeno
tiene una masa atómica promedio de 14.01, entonces
podríamos estar tentados a decir que la masa molar
del nitrógeno molecular es de 14.01 g/mol; pero
tenemos que recordar que el nitrógeno molecular
está compuesto de 2 átomos de nitrógeno, entonces
la masa molar será el doble de esto: 28.02 g/mol,
esto es igual a 28.02 g/mol. Y ahora podemos
aplicar cada una de estas ecuaciones. Entonces,
la presión parcial del argón es igual al número
de moles del argón. Voy a ponerlo en otro color
para identificar esta parte de los cálculos. Esto
será la cantidad de gramos del argón, 7.60 g por
1 entre la masa molar, entonces por 1 / 39.95
mol/g, y puedes ver que las unidades se acomodan:
los gramos se cancelan con los gramos y esto nos
dará el número de moles del argón. A esto tenemos
que multiplicarlo por la constante de los gases
ideales y debemos elegir cuál de estas utilizar,
en este caso estamos trabajando con litros, así
que estas dos funcionan bien, y la diferencia
entre ellas son las unidades de presión: la
primera está dada en atmósferas, mientras que
la segunda se da en Torr. Si queremos que nuestra
presión parcial y total esté dada en términos de
Torr podemos usar la segunda, así que hagámoslo.
En esta ocasión utilizaremos esta constante de los
gases ideales, entonces multiplicaremos por 62.36
L • Torr / mol • K. Esto tenemos que multiplicarlo
por la temperatura, para convertir 25°C en Kelvin,
bueno, sumamos 273, lo que nos da 298 Kelvin,
y todo esto lo tenemos que dividir entre nuestro
volumen que es 10.0 litros. Y podemos verificar
que las unidades funcionan: ya dijimos que los
gramos se cancelan, este mol se cancela con este
mol, este que Kelvin se cancela con este Kelvin y
este litro se cancela con este litro, y sólo nos
quedamos con Torr, que es lo que nos interesa ya
que estamos pensando en presión, en este caso la
presión parcial. Entonces tenemos 7.60 / 39.95
• 62.36 • 298 / 10.0 es igual a todo esto. Si
pensamos en cifras significativas, tenemos tres
aquí, cuatro acá, tres acá y tres acá. Siempre que
multipliquemos y dividamos utilizaremos el número
menor de cifras significativas que tengamos,
que en este caso son tres, así que vamos a
redondear a 354 Torr. Entonces, la presión parcial
del argón es de 354 Torr. Y ahora podemos hacer lo
mismo para el nitrógeno molecular, así que vamos a
hacerlo por aquí. La presión parcial del nitrógeno
molecular es igual a... y vamos a utilizar otro
color para determinar el número de moles. Esto
será la masa del nitrógeno molecular, que es 4.40
g • 1 entre la masa molar, eso es 1 / 28.02 mol/g,
y a esto lo multiplicaremos por la constante de
los gases ideales, así que básicamente podemos
copiar el resto de lo que tenemos arriba:
esto es por 62.36 L•Torr / mol • K por 298
K, todo esto entre 10 litros. Una vez más las
unidades funcionan: los gramos se cancelan con los
gramos, los moles con los moles, los litros con
los litros, Kelvin con Kelvin y nos quedaremos con
Torr. Y esto nos da, bueno, 4.40 / 28.02 • 62.36
• 298 / 10.0 nos da como resultado... Y de nuevo,
como el menor número de cifras significativas que
tenemos es tres, redondearemos esto a 292, esto es
igual a 292 Torr. Ya hemos encontrado la presión
parcial de cada uno, si queremos encontrar la
presión total sólo tenemos que sumar las presiones
parciales. Entonces será la presión parcial
del argón más la presión parcial del nitrógeno
molecular, así que esto será, lo podemos hacer
mentalmente, veamos: 646 Torr, y hemos acabado.